foreign
from an ancient ceremony into a modern
world the crowned King Charles III
and waiting for him in the 260 year old
gold State coach his Queen the title
held by his mother now his wives
even with eight horses the four-ton
gilded Carriage can only be pulled at
walking pace
but Majesty is in part about being
magical and it seems there are millions
captivated by it
[Music]
be it the fairy tale carriages or the
Splendor of a 4 000 strong military
parade
or the family Saga the embarrassing
uncle on Parade
and Rebel's son now best-selling author
pitching up without his wife
and the coach carrying the dutiful
future heirs to the throne
it is soap opera mixed with the Opera of
Royal pageantry
an elected official couldn't do what
they do it's just so perfect they're
Allure
just be fairy tale it brings everybody
together there's Unity that's a sort of
it's the proudness of being British it's
it's that's what the Monarch is all
about
thousands have come here just to be in
Touching distance of History because of
course a coronation is something we've
not experienced in decades but for that
same reason it's left others asking
whether we've moved on from what it
represents
there was a Zone set aside for
protesters but some mixed with the
royalists on the Mao
one here arrested for bringing a
megaphone that police said may have
spooked the horses I feel strongly that
we should have we should elect any head
of state or any anybody with any
ceremonial
responsibility and we've got a wonderful
country full of talented people who who
aren't who don't inherit privilege and
wealth
but most came here to Revel in a legacy
they don't want to end earlier watching
on a giant screen in St James's Park the
moment the King was crowned
but invited to pledge allegiance I I
swear that I will take no one had the
words to hand
except this bit
here we go I think it's just an
absolutely incredible moment uh one that
I'm glad I got out of bed for in the
morning to come and witness what a
historic day absolutely fantastic you
know Long Live King Charles III I'm
actually proud to be British I love what
he does for the country I love the royal
family first off and I think we need
continuity and we need somebody who can
represent everything about the
traditions of this country
discontinuity but unfamiliarity too in
seeing a man so many years a prince now
head of state head of the Church of
England and head of the Armed Forces
for his majesty the king and her majesty
the queen
[Applause]
saluted by those who serve under him in
Buckingham Palace Gardens
his authority rests on regimented
formality and the passion of the public
whether they connect with him
certainly there was a rush on the Mao
for the best view of the finale
[Applause]
but in some ways the endurance of the
last Monarch makes this rebirth harder
her absence still felt as the king
appeared on this balcony for the first
time ever without his mother
instead a blended family grandchildren
from both sides taking Center Stage
notably missing one brother and one son
these are the faces of the future the
working Roy
and those who are next in line to take
on this role
at Royal occasions we're used to such as
weddings and jubilees this is not just a
celebration but a day to affirm the
Majesty of one man
the late Queen described the Imperial
Crown resting on Charles's head as
unwieldy
now he will know what it's like to wear
it Jason Farrell Sky News
[Applause]